yeah they're expected at any time  actually I'm in polista which is where  you can see the Lula supporters have  come out in huge numbers and they  haven't really started to get going yet  um there's I mean there's thousands of  people here it's a huge road but um as  it stands now Lula is just ahead it's  about over a million votes ahead of uh  president bolsonaro as it stands and why  that's good for molay what usually  happens is his votes get stronger  towards the end of the count so he could  look like increasing his vote quite soon  just have to wait and see it's going to  be quite a night here as you can imagine  Stuart to thank you